hello everyone and a special welcome to
all you uncles joining this episode of
versus i'm your host mark allison today
on the show it's a voracious villain
vanity affair as i have the vexing task
of determining once and for all who is
the greatest spider-man evil doer to
ever walk the earth or float above it on
a cool jet glider thing look we all know
and love spidey on the big screen no
matter if his true identity is peter
parker or miles morales and the box
office indicates that we don't really
care who's playing him we just want the
most web wicking for our wallet but when
it comes to spidey's antagonists we
might be a bit more like those moms that
prefer jif peanut butter because we're
choosy
it's a terrible joke
but thank you for coming the list of
villainous presences that have been a
thorough in spite each side is long and
distinguished and before i reveal our
starting lineup i have to first
apologize to all those baddies that
didn't quite make the cut electro i
thought you look cool but i only have so
much time before rotten tomato security
realizes that once again i broke into
the studio sandman you're out as well
but the good news is you're only a few
pounds of spice away from being a good
guy in the next dune film rhino don't
worry you didn't make the cut but you'll
be referenced off in this episode
because i love making fun of you and the
biggest oversight of all that thief that
unceremoniously sent uncle ben to the
river styx i'm an uncle myself and my
nephew wanted to be spider-man for this
past halloween luckily i talked him into
being colonel mustard and now here's the
starting lineup for your chicago bull i
mean spider-man villains from spider-man
1 and 3 and the amazing spider-man 2
green goblin from spider-man 2 and into
the spider-verse dr octopus
from spider-man far from home mysterio
from spider-man homecoming vulture from
daredevil really the daredevil netflix
show come on stop we're doing this and
into the spider-verse oh right it's
kingpin
and from north carolina but also
spider-man 3 in his own franchise number
23
venom
that's truly a who's who of bad eggs
misguided geniuses and symbiotic life
forms not since batman and robin have so
many villains been crammed into one
piece of entertainment and this vid will
probably be just as popular as that 1997
best picture winner thanks razzies
here's how we'll determine our winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
unlimited power round four iconic
moments and then we'll do a wild card
round that might involve who can drive a
truck while mumbling in a thick russian
accent to themselves the best i kid i
joke and occasionally i might even
elicit a guffaw or a turtle from you
dear bjork
but i'm well aware how meaningful and
important villains have been to
spider-man lore after all what good is a
peter parker slinging web go around new
york unless he's doing it to combat evil
these nasty folks should be commended
for being so evil they forced spidey's
hand and with it this set like web
substance and it's also clear to me your
host and judge that with great power
comes great responsibility
oh usually after someone says that they
get killed we'll see how many rounds i
make it let's get it on
round one box office thanks in large
part to these villainous presences
spider-man movies have been slaying at
the box office ever since the first
flick bound in theaters on may 3rd 2002.
my mom's birthday was the day before but
good son that i am i couldn't get her a
gift anywhere close to resembling the
bounty that awaited director sam ramey
and star toby mcguire she got a scarf
just in time for summer
that spidey flick would become the
fastest film to cross the 100 million
dollar mark at the domestic box office
shattering the records set by the darth
maul stunt show three years prior the
movie wouldn't stop the chugwan there as
it went on to nap 821 million dollars in
theaters worldwide spidey 3 would even
top that feat grossing 895 million why
did i skip spider-man 2 arguably the
best comic book movie ever well because
green goblin isn't in that one silly
goose he shows up in part one as norman
osborne then his kid harry picks up the
mantle in part three then a different
harry altogether tried it out for the
amazing spider-man 2 which oh by the way
did 709 million dollars worldwide it
would have been a billion if rhino got
to lead the flick i'm just saying you're
young
you don't understand how the world works
gaudy numbers out of the gate for double
g as his worldwide total over three
movies is 2.42 billion dollars making
for a per flick average of 808 million
that almost two and a half billion
dollar accumulation is still the record
for anybody wanting to take on spidey
but dr osborne is he a real doctor or
just one of those phds he'll have some
stiff competition from another dock but
first he also rans look i love kingpin
and his ultimate dad bod and all the
midlife crisis strength in the world but
it can't make up for the fact that he's
only in one prominent big screen role
and that was when he was chasing around
ben affleck in a daredevil costume that
movie by the way still did 555
million dollars worldwide which shows
you just how competitive this match is
gonna be kingpin you can relax in the
green room for now but you will be a
factor later in the ball game as for
this round omg it's a tag team walking
into the ring vulture and mysterio
showed up together because they're both
in the mcu spidey films and might show
up again sometime soon to mysterio
michael keaton's vulture tortured peter
in his high school puppy love
aspirations in homecoming to the tune of
880 million dollars in global bucks jake
gyllenhaal's mysterio upped the ante and
far from home which hauled in an
astronomical 1.1 billion dollars in
earthling coin that was a setup right he
claimed to be from a different earth but
was actually just some special effects
nerd from patterson new jersey it's easy
to fool people when they're already
fooling themselves anyway both impressed
and they're one major outing so far but
only one spidey villain was so popular
he got his own franchise that's right
the coolest looking character in comic
book history and whose senior quote was
that turd in the wind line please
welcome venom to the stage fans were
begging to see venom in the sam raimi
trilogy and finally got their wish when
topher grace aka alternate earth mark
ellis played eddie brock in spitey three
and as much as i enjoyed amnesia grip
james franco in that film there's no
doubt the majority of that 895 million
dollar take was thanks to venom not the
possibility of another goblet appearance
venom then struck out on his own and met
his soul mate tom hardy and the pair's
accurately titled film venom debuted in
the fall of 2018 making 854 million
dollars before it was all said and done
the 2021 sequel let there be carnage has
grows to shade under 400 million dollars
so far though at the time of this taping
it's got a few more weeks before it
heads to streaming services and your
local blockbuster video shout out bend
oregon venom is a force to be reckoned
with in this round as he's the only
other villain besides green goblin to
notch a total raking of over 2 billion
and the dude sports an impressive 716
million dollar per movie average and
finally the doctor is in that's the good
news bad news is he's the doc with what
are they four or eight arms or legs or
limbs it's dr octopus and said foe made
their sinister debut in spider-man 2 and
also showed up in into the spider verse
spidey two saw doc ock played by alfred
molina and it was the great katherine
hahn voicing dr olivia octavius in the
spider verse both iterations helped
usher in buffo box office making for a
combined
1.16 billion dollars for a per film take
of 582 million and as much coin as that
is this round has come down to a
two-horse race one of whom has a cool
hover glider contraption thing green
goblin has enjoyed the spoils of comic
book warfare by being a pest for both
toby maguire and andrew garfield and as
such has the highest total and per film
average of any villain in contention but
venom was also in a toby spidey before
pulling a peter gabriel and going solo
and eddie brock was a much bigger draw
than harry osborne by the time sam
raimi's last spidey flick came out hey
we might get another ramy spider guy
when his doctor strange movie comes out
right man the mcu the gift it keeps on
giving the fact is no other baddie could
have opened their own movie much less
done a franchise with anywhere near the
success sported by venom his one outing
in a spider movie was competitive with
the two mcu arachnid films thus far and
as much as i respect double g if it's
just him on the poster i'm probably
renting it at a red box outside 7-eleven
venom takes round one and goes up on all
the other villains one to nothing
get out
round two tomato meter slash audience
score it's a big w for venom especially
in a matchup that's only five rounds
long and we have six villainous entities
competing after consulting with a
classroom of algebra 2 students
brilliant but lazy
that means that after today's match at
least one baddie will be empty-handedly
walking home or to the nearest bar to
drown their sorrows with rhino but now
it's venom who has the honor which is
golf speak for you get to go first but
that could be a dubious honor for old
eddie brock because this round is all
about what the critics and fans had to
say after they saw your flick the good
part for venom is that dude's got two
movies that are fresh on the tomato
meter the bad part is the highest rated
film of his is only barely deodorized at
63 percent you want to guess which one
i'll wait it's spider-man 3. is rotten
tomatoes wrong about that roxy streier
clearly thought so and she was a guest
on our podcast and she's a boston sports
fan so she knows how to light up a
scoreboard venom's first solo foray was
very rotten laning at just 30 percent on
the tomato meter but let there be
carnage has rebounded thus far with a
current 60 fresh number the audience
scores better news especially for 2018's
venom it's at 81 percent and the sequel
is even higher at 84
problem is lots of people saw spider-man
3 and they weren't as thrilled about
seeing me play the role its audience
score is rotten at 51 overall the
character is still fresh according to
the audience averaging 72 percent per
movie the long tongued one heads down
south to rottentown with a 51 average on
the tomato meter to further rub salt in
the wound it's okay he can kind of heal
himself right can all comic book
characters do that to some degree venom
is the only villain who has any rotten
average on either metric even kingpin
wasn't too weighed down by the
theatrical daredevil film and his
averages are 77.6 in the tomato patch
and 72 percent in the audience's garden
a workshop that term i know a tune
called octopuses garden and even the
beatles would marvel at how prolific doc
ock has been on the big screen two
flicks and both are as super fresh as
the fab four when they debuted on the ed
sullivan show into the spider-verse got
all the audiences loving with the 93 and
the critics loved it even more with a 97
tomato meter score spider-man 2 is at a
fresh 93 with the critics and an 82
percent with the audience score thus
making for a perfect average of 95 and
87.5 respectively green goblin can't
follow that lead but he's at least fresh
on both averages norman and harry
combined for a 68.3 per flick score on
the tomato meter and a 60.6 average on
the audience side of things thanks
amazing spider-man 2 and spider-man 3.
the one-off villains are the real
threats to professor squid here mysterio
dominates both metrics with a 90 fresh
in the tomato meter and a 95 on the
audience score
see that wasn't so hard
[Applause]
vulture balances him out perfectly with
a 92 tomato meter freshness and then a
rosie 87 percent for the audience score
which begs the question can michael
keaton and jake gyllenhaal do bubble boy
2 together
no please you're still on that i told
you no the answer is no forget it but
those are only one movie per villain
whereas dr octopus set a new standard in
good intentions gone bad back in 2004
and doc ock was a super fun addition
once we fell into the spider verse and
although your host who loves men's
warehouse you and i are not so different
hasn't seen the new spidey flick yet i
saw the trailer and doc ock is helping
sell that movie in a major way which is
going to be more than enough to award
them the win in round number two medical
degree or not ock has one point venom
has one point and everyone else feels
like a certain something rolling down
the street in the wind round three
unlimited power there's really nothing
better in this world than raw untamed
power unless of course you've been able
to harness that potential into a precise
evil scheme that could put the very fate
of the universe at stake villains love
their special abilities just as much as
our superheroes the only difference is
when these baddies flex their mean
muscle it could spell doom for us fire
all the drones now
that's a very loose us because we're the
audience and sure we like the innocent
bystanders we're watching on the big
screen to pull through but part of what
makes us ooh ah and shove popcorn into
her face is that these heralded villains
bring so much to the playing field so
who's got the best powers let's start
with you rhino hey look at you driving a
truck angry and fast look out old ladies
crossing the street
kingpin gets major points in this round
simply because of what he has done i
killed spider-man it's true in my
favorite spider-themed flick of all time
into the spider-verse kingpin manages to
off a spidey and in doing so flexus is
super villain muscle which is i mean
it's muscle but he's definitely on a
protein and carb loading phase because
he's bulky all the way around and has
been since we saw michael clark duncan
first portray him in 2004's daredevil
vincent d'onofrio also brought a lot of
mass to the netflix series and it served
him well in jail that and a tremendous
amount of pure rage very few things can
soften his inner demons and high
schoolers named peter are not one of
them while kingpin would win a
powerlifting contest in any gold's gym
around the world venom's powers are
largely not of this earth the alien
symbiote that becomes bffs with eddie
brock is capable of alien features like
super strength speed and the enviable
ability to bite off heads venom is also
a good listener occasionally at least
when his other half is giving the
instructions he can inflict damage in a
variety of ways including just as eddie
topher grace's portrayal of the classic
spidey anti-hero shows us a competitive
photojournalist who dare i say may be
better at taking snapshots than peter
parker come on you know it's true look i
root for the kid but he ain't exactly
annie liebowitz as for mysterio now
we're talking he's got the greatest
powers of anyone in the field today if
the question is who's the front runner
at a job interview for lucasfilm while
he's in good shape pulls off the costume
incredibly well and has a neck that's
capable of stabilizing that fishbowl on
top of his noggin most of mysterio's
abilities are an illusion so he might
lose a fisticuffs with venom or kingpin
in a ufc cage match you're probably
right about that but his tomfoolery and
trickery are so intricately planned out
that he pulled a host of intelligent
people in places like joy old england
and that's where oxford university is
they don't let dummies in there i'm not
even allowed to set foot on the campus
with my wake forest 2.1 gpa your parents
must be very proud and he really threw
spider-man for a loop mysterio is a
valid foe in this round because
outsmarting your opponent and being able
to sell tickets in vegas are a valued
commodity and as we look at our roster
so far it seems like vulture might be
the best combination of all of these
abilities michael keaton's portrayal
brings us the old man strength of a
kingpin the illusionary skills of
mysterio and the extraterrestrial tech
of a venom and the best part he can
drive almost as angrily as rhino vulture
earned that moniker from flying which is
something most daddies of high school
kids can't do without a plane ticket but
he has chitari weaponry recovered and
restored from him and his team after the
new york battle seen in the climax of
the avengers he can fly with his suit
and those power cells make him a
formidable enemy to all superheroes
including tony stark with whom he has a
personal vendetta oh and when he goes up
against spidey it's not just villain
versus hero it's daddy versus boy dating
my little girl and pete as a guy who's
been in your shoes have her home by 10
p.m of all the different goblins we see
battle sir parker it's norman osborne
that would appear to pose the biggest
threat although i'll give points to
harry because he's the one that
ultimately ended gwen's bid for romance
norm and dr octavius are similar
creatures they're brainiacs who might
mean well but go way too far in their
pursuit of scientific advancement green
goblin gains the ability to zip around
on a hovercraft otto grows some new
appendages and becomes the first octopus
ever to survive on land for more than 14
minutes they also both harbor that
intimidating teacher-student stronghold
over peter parker it's tough enough to
take on a run-of-the-mill bad guy it's
even worse when it's someone with whom
you've had a positive interaction with
that same feeling might extend to james
franco's portrayal of harry and
spider-man 3 because now spidey has to
deal with someone who was his best
friend but for all the untold ability
housed by venom the patriarchal tyranny
of a kingpin a goblin or an octopus or
the funkle betrayal of mysterio i'm
going with vulture
yes i love me some michael keaton and we
can feel every bit of his internal rage
in that performance but it's also the
perfect melding of every other
villainous power in play alien tech aged
man angst and a personal discrepancy
with spider-man now i might have
considered vulture even if he was
happy-go-lucky adrian who was concerned
his baby was dating some scrawny kid
like peter parker now if we toss in the
chitari blue lightning stuff that's a
done deal vulture gets the point and is
on the board it's a three-way tie for
the lead between vulture venom and doc
ock round four iconic moments now let's
have some fun after all what good are
those alien tools and rage and muscles
if they just sit idly by for two hours
or sometimes two hours and 45 minutes
with post credit scenes let's take all
that potential and put it to real use in
the round that will only reward the
coolest fight scenes the baddest villain
snarls and the thickest of russian
accents
all joking aside whatever scenes i
reference or moments that you see play
over my handsome face don't tell harry
i'm kidding that's the final line
uttered by green goblin after yet
another epic clash betwixt him and
spidey it's an emotional resolution that
hits peter hard and the look on parker's
face through his tattered mask hits home
with audiences i love this moment
because it showed the world we can get
attached to heroes and villains and
whoever wins we're going to feel some
level of emotion for the loser of course
goblin didn't lose every fight he had
with the web slinger their first bout is
epic and the lack of musical
accompaniment really means something
spider-man looks a lot more like spider
boy here as he's clearly outwitted by a
more experienced veteran opponent and
even when the neighborhood guy is on the
ground it's not always going to end well
gwen stacy isn't just in concussion
protocol after that climactic clash with
dane dehaan's green goblin in the
amazing spider-man 2 she is a goner the
action flies fast and makes dennis leary
furious with the outcome but it missed
all the punches and athleticism and
swelling music it's still the sound of
stacy's head hitting the concrete that
gets me every time dr octopus owns at
least one iconic moment we can all
recall that train fight it's still so
damn cool the stakes the imagination the
speed at which the clash is occurring
the battle is one of the key reasons
that you could argue spidey 2 is still
the best comic book film of all time but
for me equally as awesome would be the
bank fight and the super collider war
and into the spider-verse olivia has an
absolute ball when she's revealed to be
the new doc ocon ochentown in my humble
opinion the best scenes of any owned by
the good bad doctor are the ones that
clearly indicate the horror background
that director sam raimi had witnessed
the classic monster lab experiment gone
wrong moment and then when otto wakes up
and he's got the arms but his arms
already woke up people died kingpin
might be the most inspirational to me
amateur weightlifter mark ellis i may
not be invited to muscle beach this
summer but seeing kingpin put up bruce
willis in unbreakable bench press
numbers is just as motivational as
watching a rocky training montage of
course he's getting in shape for much
more nefarious purposes prison riots are
just for fun for real kicks how about a
decapitation or subverting fans hopes by
offing reporter ben ulrich in his own
home you're not safe from this guy
anywhere kingpin's had many memorable
duels with daredevil but in into the
spider-verse the final fight is brutal
and once again he kills spider-man no
one else in competition today can put
that in their obituary venom may not
care to as he's never been painted as
the arch-nemesis to spider-man like some
of these others have but that doesn't
mean we don't get plenty of great
sequences starting with any instance of
the symbiote and eddie brock having an
argument it's great fun checking out the
couple like bickering in tom hardy's run
and as great as that final clash in
2018's venom is i might love the
zaniness of the lobster restaurant scene
even more you want to know the tone this
franchise is going for you'll find it in
the lobster tank let's also let the suit
itself have some fun anyone want to go
dancing oh this divided fans into the
theater opening day and 14 years later
still raises eyebrows but the round is
called iconic moments and the jazz club
emo spidey sequence certainly has
staying power mysterio may have been a
one and done or maybe not but boy what a
show the elemental fights and far from
home are a visual effects hoot from
start to finish and jake gyllenhaal's
ginormous puppy dog eyes went an extra
sense of gravitas when he broham chats
with peter parker's clearly searching
for both himself and a new father figure
at the same time and the quiet
conversations he has with quentin beck
my name is mysterio
hold true weight even if it's all a load
of crap go back and watch the bar scene
where peter misguidedly hands over the
magic tony stark glasses it's great for
two reasons one even we the audience are
buying the bs that mysterio is selling
and two how funny is it to see a full-on
superhero costume on a guy swilling a
budweiser man i miss san diego comic-con
see you all july 2022. intimate convos
between a mentor and mentee are nice but
awkward get to know you chats are even
more fun and a tense car ride to the big
dance vulture and spidey have some
awesome battle sequences but none are
more personal or chess-like than the war
of words and rear view mirror eye
darting that ensues when daddy gives mj
and her new boy a lift to the fish under
the sea soiree oh in that epic fairy
fight vulture proves his worth in the
pantheon of movie baddies when he slices
a huge watercraft in half and is such a
threat that iron man has to swoop in
just to match wits fun fact time our own
expert researcher mark hoffmeyer was on
that boat oh sorry i read that wrong
okay so i'm being told the fight itself
was fictional but the hoff worked on
that movie and saw the ship being built
on the studio lot in atlanta congrats on
your world series atl hammer and hank
would be proud vulture and mysterio's
combination of death defying stunts and
meaningful mono amano chats make a
strong case in this round but they only
had one flick so far to get all that in
and while homecoming and far from home
are both great spider-man 2 has been
elevated into mount olympus movie status
because of the might of doc ock and
olivia octavius and into the
spider-verse uh speaking of mount
olympus flicks seals the deal the doctor
is in with another win in round four and
takes the outright lead two to one to
one to zero to zero to zero to rhino and
now it's time for the wild card round
arc of the covenant even if the classic
arc is spelled with a k and is currently
being examined by top men
top
men this very average boy who is barely
a man now hosts the wild card round that
will take a deep dive into the backstory
villainous heights and ultimate resting
place of these nerd due wells competing
today who is truly the most interesting
villain spider-man has ever gone against
vulture and kingpin have both made that
neighborhood hero decidedly less
friendly and both are fueled by the rage
sewn into their genetic makeup by their
past lives for kingpin it was a brutal
upbringing at the hands of a mafia
what's the word kingpin daddy would come
home and take out his angst on the
family until little kingpin did what
became a habit he killed the guy yep
once you off your old man it's game on
for whoever wants a piece next but by
all accounts adrian toomes was less in
need of a mental health expert that is
until his salvage company in charge of
cleaning up the big apple after the
interstellar war in the adventures is
driven out of business by stark
enterprises you'd think tone would at
least invite them to the social media
friendly party they have at the outset
of age of ultron but no they didn't even
get a christmas card the good news for
fans of these two villains is that
they're in the slammer but still alive
and kicking unless you're the movie
version of kingpin because you got your
legs pretty banged up as it stands
vulture is in prison but maybe not for
long venom is positively thriving at the
moment in large part because he's the
hero of his own story and i gotta say
getting swallowed up by alien goo may
have been the best thing that ever
happened to eddie brock now this
flailing investigative journalist has a
story better yet he's living his own
scoop it's ultimately hilarious and
horrific and nothing short of endearing
to us the audience but when venom was a
true thorn in spider-man's side all the
hype turned into a whimper by the end of
spider-man 3. mysterio's backstory may
have packed an emotional wild if we
hadn't just seen a similar version with
vulture this time it was a one-time
employee of tony stark who felt betrayed
after getting canned and decided to join
forces with newly unemployed stark
enterprises refugees it's nonetheless
compelling but mysterio is at his
devilishly best when his own confidence
is what gets the best of him or when
he's spilling the beans about spidey's
real identity to j jonah jameson
somewhat similar to quentin beck and
adrian toomes both norman osborne and
otto octavius weren't always a-holes
hell-bent on mass destruction they were
both in a rush to get their experiments
to the finish line and in doing so made
themselves part of the process in
norman's case he and the military pull
its funding of oscorp in favor of
another contract with rival company
quest i know them well and my favorite
flavor is cookies and cream otto and his
better half are employed at ozcorp and
spider-man 2 and they're working on a
powerful reactor project that will help
humanity but in a lab accident you know
there's really a criminal lack of safety
checks in comic book laboratories mrs
octavius dies and otto is left with
these nutcase appendages attached to him
villainy ensues but i was always kind of
rooting for anno weren't you not so much
for norman which might make norman the
better villain but going back to otto
look i can understand a sense into
madness otto fought it hard and olivia
makes it hilarious and into the
spider-verse norm seems like he's been
secretly waiting for this opportunity
his whole life and he whacks a
high-ranking military officer just as
his opening salvo goblin's villainy is
further intensified by the friends
forever pact that we thought his son
harry and peter had and then when yet
another goblin ends gwen's run at life
it becomes a done deal both characters
had the luxury of their backstory told
in riveting in depth fashion that made
us care about them before they turned to
the dockside but goblin packed a little
more emotional punch to peter and that's
what gets them the edge in the wild card
round goblin takes it and we're tied at
the top two to two this is a
breakthrough beyond your father's dreams
thank you which means i have the
thankless task of choosing one of these
two great villainous entities is my
winner today it's a lot of pressure and
you'd think i could avoid this weight as
i am the guy who writes these ted talks
uh can you just fast forward to the end
both baddies start out friendly then get
super dark then have a redemptive moment
towards the end because after all the
best villains are the ones that thought
they were the good guy but the tales of
och and goblin end with a slight
difference goblin loses to spidey and
dies meanwhile doc ock chooses to
sacrifice himself after coming out of a
wicked coma which makes his nefarious
return possibility in a future
spider-man film all the more tempting
and we get to see another incarnation in
olivia so i go with dr octopus as my
winner octopi all around the world
celebrate oh rosie i love this boy well
we had fun today and that was a tough
call there at the end but of course it's
just my opinion and i'm only one man at
least until the spider verse opens back
up and an alternate earth mark shows up
to usurp my power and maybe star in that
70s show fun fact i met topher grace at
chipotle one time and we became besties
no joke we ordered the same exact
burrito same meat beans rice fixings and
we both were okay with the extra charge
for guac okay versus first now it's your
turn who you got is your favorite
spider-man foe let your voice be heard
by hitting me up on social media i'm at
mark ellis live on twitter and instagram
be sure to check back here at rotten
tomatoes for more episodes and until
next time in the words of a great uncle
with great power comes i don't want to
say it because i know what happens next
i'm just going to end the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]